je t'appelle parce que je suis vraiment
inquiète pour ta soeur de budget avec
adam je sais pas et comme changer c'est
avec cette mise en situation que
commence le jeu d'évasion les
participants doivent aller chercher des
indices dans la roulotte où le couple
parfait week-end de camping à la poster
sur son instinct qui partent en
randonnée pour être allé voir sur des
indices qui prouvent que j'ai raison le
but identifier la relation amoureuse du
couple est saine ou malsaine c'est parti
je pense que d'une façon immersive et
réaliste de sensibiliser les jeunes à la
violence amoureuse dont des revenants
prévention primaire revenir un peu en
arrière pour donner des outils aux
jeunes puis un moyen qui puisse être
aussi pour faire face à leur première
relation amoureuse
comment on dit ça parce que c'est à
l'adolescence que se cristallisent
certains comportements de relation de
couple
je pense qu'on sème une graine mélanie
volonté travail auprès des femmes
victimes de violences conjugales
il a participé à la scénarisation du
programme privant qu'être bon on croit
que quand on discute de ça déjà tout
jeune mais ça va juste fbi a identifié
un lien commun parce que les formes de
violence sont extrêmement méconnu des
textos hargneux insistante de la
jalousie excessive
les jeunes sont appelés à discuter des
indices qu'ils ont trouvé ce qui me fait
réagir ses messages textes le texte soit
sur la violence commence par les to je
recoupe norme est de baisser mais dont
adamo moissin selon moi c'est les 2,6 mb
qu'en son temps avant nice font
confiance et c'est ça qui est malsain
c'est plus comme il manque de confiance
il vraiment trop jaloux ça démontre à
quel point que la jalousie ça pète ça
peut être emporté
vraiment n'importe quel moment faire des
ravages
on ou non une centaine de jeunes ont
participé au programme qui intéressent
d'autres corps policiers à travers la
province
une version adaptée de privant quête
sera également offerte dans certaines
classes de 4e secondaire dès l'an
prochain
si jacques audrey chardenoux reste du
canada mon frère